- Hey guys, welcome to Spoiler Party.
I've just invited a
bunch of my friends over
to watch the terrifying
new movie, Hereditary,
and we just got our
socks scared off of us.
It was bonkers crazy, so let's
check out what just happened.
(techno music)
(suspenseful music)
(knock at door)
- Come on, Peter.
Here's your suit.
- Premiered at Sundance,
it's been described as
"the most traumatically
terrifying horror movie in ages,"
"tragic, evil, and so (censored) scary."
I saw it yesterday.
I'm still shook by it.
Tensions are running
high on set right now.
Why don't we go around the
room and do introductions,
and guys, tell me whether or
not you like horror movies?
- I'm Christian, I've been a big
horror film fanatic since I was a kid.
I can't wait.
This guy next to me, kind
of almost sweating already.
- I'm Garrett, I hate scary movies.
So mad I'm here.
We'll see.
- I'm Kate, and I hate scary movies.
I'm not even trying to suck up,
but A24 makes really good movies,
so I feel like if they
make a horror movie,
I'm going to (censored) my pants.
- I'm Eli.
I only get scared if I'm with
someone that gets scared.
(Kate laughing)
- We watched the original Jumanji movie.
- I was full of joy,
and he was very spooked
- There were elephants
- watching Jumanji.
- running around.
- What do you guys think
this movie is about
after watching the trailer?
- Hobby Lobby project gone wrong?
- A grandma dies and
they're all sad and weird.
- I think what I'm really scared about
is like I'm going to find
myself in these characters.
- So, you're afraid you're gonna find
this movie too relatable?
(all laughing)
Okay.
- I already wanna throw up.
- The tree house?
- [Sam] The tree house is not traumatic.
- Yeah, that tree house is disgusting.
- That's a damn nice tree house.
- So far, I'm doing okay.
- It's been fifteen seconds.
- If the music was
(humming an upbeat tune).
- I don't wanna hobby shame anyone,
but I feel like if I
walked into someone's house
and this was there, I'd be like, get out.
- If that dog dies--
- [Garret] That dog
doesn't know he's acting.
That dog's just walking around.
- No, he doesn't know he's
in the scariest movie ever.
- [Annie] She could be
the sweetest, warmest,
most loving person in the world.
(disgusted gasps)
- That dude probably doesn't
know any of those people.
He just goes to, like, funeral homes.
- She was also incredibly
stubborn. (tongue clicks)
- I hate this noise.
- All I can see is Alyssa Edwards
whenever I hear that noise.
- Oh yeah! (clicks tongue)
- Like, every straight
person is like, "wait, what?"
(Alyssa clicks tongue)
- Who's gonna take care of me?
- (scoffs) Um, excuse me.
You don't think I'm
gonna take care of you?
- But when you die...
- When a kid says "but when
you die," you'd be like,
"Honey, that's not gonna
happen for a long,"
you know what I mean?
- I don't think that child has
good intentions with anything.
- A kid says "You're gonna
die" and then just walk away?
Like I'm completely
(censored) freaked out.
- I used to ask my great-aunt, I was like,
"How many more days until
you die?" (laughing)
- Oh my god, you were that kid!
- When I was little, 'cause
I didn't understand it.
- I was about to say, are they banging?
Poor guy, look at his face.
- That's what you feel bad for him for?
(group laughing)
- Just add it on to everything else.
Oh snap! (censored)
- Have you had any experience
with paranormal activity?
- Hell yeah, I grew up
in haunted house man.
- Really?
- Like, five years of my
life when I was a kid.
It was the worst.
(bird hits window, caws)
- [Kids In Class] Oh
my God, what was that?
- Here it is, scissors.
- Oh snap.
Oh my god, she's back with chocolate bars.
- Back with the chocolates,
staring at the bird.
(Kate exclaiming)
- Oh!
- Did she take the head or the body?
- She took the head, and she
also took a bite of chocolate.
- I'm not creeped out by
the little girl at all.
She cut off a bird's head,
but like, kids are weird.
People that are acting
strange are the adults.
- The mom knows something
that we don't know yet.
- Yes.
- She knows there's something
weird in her family.
- How scared are we, one to ten?
- That (censored) got
me spooked a little bit.
That took me to, like, a five.
- I'm more curious than scared right now.
- I'm like probably a six.
Random strangers do terrify me.
- Where you at?
- [Sam] Yeah, where, one to ten?
- I'm gonna say a two.
And it's only because the
tension just keeps building.
- I'm even more terrified for the dog now
after I saw what she did to the bird.
(Eli gasps)
- You don't think she's
gonna do that to the dog?
Like cut the dog's head off?
- If something does
happen to the dog, could someone warn me
so I could close my ears and eyes?
- Oh, I hate long hallways.
- Well, when I grew up in a haunted house,
it was like, what do you do?
(others laughing)
Coming from experience.
- Wait, we never came back to that!
- Yeah, can we talk about that?
- There was a little door
that was like the attic,
and you close it.
No matter how much you
close it, it still opens.
Like (imitates creaking door)
I moved out first to go to school.
My mom closed up the house,
and on the last night,
she went to the kitchen in
the middle of the night,
she saw a little boy.
Everything happened in the kids' room.
- He's like "Aww sweet,
kids here to play with!"
Like Casper.
- No, it sucked.
- But you know if there's
ever a dead little boy,
there's something else too.
I'm getting out of there.
(group laughing)
- Let's see what happens next.
- Holy shit! Huge party
tomorrow at Aaron's house!
- Bring your dick?
Where were those parties
at in high school?
Like they were not that cool.
- Damn, he's horny as hell.
- Oh my god.
- Oh, (censored)!
(Eli screaming)
- What?
- No!
I did not see that coming.
- That really upset me.
- You okay, mom?
- What?
- Just seems like there might
be something you wanna say.
- Yeah.
- Like what?
I mean, why would I wanna say something
so I can watch you sneer at me?
- Sneer at you?
I don't ever sneer at you.
- Oh sweetie, you don't have to.
You get your point across.
- She's on crack.
- Momma's 'bout to snap.
- Don't you swear at me,
you little (censored)!
Don't you ever raise your voice at me!
I am your mother!
- This is too much pent-up
sexual frustration,
pent-up a lot of things.
- You keep focusing on that.
I don't think that's the primary--
- Eli, what's going on with you, buddy?
- You're sleeping on the
husband, that's all I'm saying.
He's gonna come out and do something.
- At least somebody's
sleeping on the husband.
- Some, ayy!
- What happened?
(Joan laughs)
- I don't even know if I should say.
- What do you mean?
- You're gonna think I am crazy.
- No, not at all.
- Is it in Palm Springs?
- That's not Palm Springs.
(group laughing)
Palm Springs is amazing... and gay.
You why this is so (censored) up?
I haven't seen one gay
person in this movie.
- Where's the representation?
- That you know of.
- I met a spiritual medium.
- Joan's a bad influence.
- They were performing an open seance.
I know, I know what you're thinking.
- Oh my god, I hate chalkboards.
- Oh, he better not say "Help."
- Don't chant anything you don't know.
- The minute that glass
moved, I'd be out the door.
- I feel like that's a warning sign.
- Joan's a little cray cray.
Can't be dipping in the
portal, spirit worlds.
Can't be doing it!
- I've dipped in the sauce.
- That is not sauce, that is
like haunted demon (censored).
- I'm just getting throwback
memories of my childhood.
- Kate was talking about
how she was nervous
that she was gonna relate
to this movie too much,
but I feel like you...
- It's bringing a lot
back, and I don't like it.
- How scared are you guys right now?
- We got a four or five now.
It's ramping up.
- I can't put my finger on handle of it.
I can't handle on the finger....
I don't know what's going on.
(group laughing)
- Great.
That wasn't a number, but thank you.
I'm at a seven.
- I'll say I'm at a five,
'cause now I know she's got the tools to
really start (censored) up.
- Wait, it's not really quite
Jumanji-level scared yet.
- I think they have escapes right now.
In Jumanji, those kids can't escape.
Alright?
(group laughing)
Here, they could just
drive to New York City.
All this stuff happens in the woods
where there's no witnesses,
where it's all far away,
where people get crazy
ideas in their head.
I think I'm very clear about this,
I would move to New York City.
(laughing)
(ominous music)
(head slamming on desk)
(students in class scream)
- [Sam] This movie is good.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's pretty good.
- This movie keeps picking and prodding
and you keep going up.
- It's almost like a series
of, like, small moments.
- Oh, this is what got him!
- Oh, I feel so bad for the dad.
- Steve did not sign up for this.
When you're 20, you can be
a sucker for a wounded bird,
but then eventually, you have to be like,
"Okay, is this sustainable?"
- I think that dog peaced
out of this place, for sure.
- Oh yeah, that dog had
a door slammed on it.
That dog's like "I'm out.
"I'm not getting disrespected like this."
- Homeward Bound-ing this shit real quick.
- Oh!
Oh my god.
- This is at a 10 right now.
- That's the guy from the (censored).
(group screaming)
- Ooh, got the little goosebumps.
- Don't!
Don't!
- Oh!
- (censored), that's creepy as hell.
- I don't know if I wanna look.
- [Sam] You gotta look.
- Whoa!
(Eli gasping)
- Oh!
(Kate laughing)
- That's gonna be the next hit dance move.
(suspenseful music builds)
(group yelling)
- Jesus Christ.
- Overall, how scared were you?
- I got pretty spooked towards the end.
Usually if I go in a fight stance,
that's how I know I'm pretty shooketh.
(group yelling)
I would say it got to an eight.
- Kate?
- I'm more mad.
- At what?
- I'm mad that it was scary.
- So how scary was it?
- I don't know, maybe like a nine.
I'm trying to talk myself out
of being scared right now,
so I wanna say a four.
- You process this better than
that family was processing.
- I did, but I wanna squash it.
I want it to go away.
- No.
- I would say it's like an eight or nine.
- You handled it very well, though,
for how scared you were going in.
- Yeah I thought it was
going to be much worse.
- I feel like it would probably be like
a seven or eight overall.
- I feel like it peaks at an eight.
If I were in a theater,
I think I would've been much scared-er.
- How 'bout some Hereditary Mad Libs?
What would you describe it as?
- I'd say spooky.
- Parentheses so it's like a smiley face.
(Sam and Kate laugh)
- I just think of the amount
of dicks that were in there.
- You've never seen dick porn, have you?
- Not a lot of it.
- What about you?
- I'm gonna stick with upsetting.
- If you guys were possessed
by anyone in the world,
dead or alive, who would
you wanna be possessed by?
- I would do Oprah.
She knows what to do with her own body.
- [Sam] Mm-hmm.
- She's on this great spiritual journey.
Do it for me, girl.
- I would choose The Rock.
(Kate laughing)
He's gonna go to gym like
eighteen hours a day.
I'm gonna get super
(censored) swole with it.
I'm gonna be jacked, son.
- A dolphin, a horse, or Elon Musk.
- I love how Elon Musk was, like, the
logical conclusion if it wasn't a dolphin.
Garrett, who do you pick?
- Some French chef that I'm
suddenly able to cook so well.
- Who did you pick?
- Ellen, because I
already kind of look her,
so I feel like she would be like "Oh!"
Oh, I kind of dress like her too.
- We're so sorry, Ellen.
You do not dress like him.
- Thanks for watching Spoiler Party,
and (censored) your pants with us
as we watched Hereditary.
Make sure to like the video
and also comment below
what movie you want us to watch next.
(techno music)